as a Fox News Alert for you the
president has just released a memo about
declassification he says he wants to
release information about spying on his
campaign back in 2016 Fox's David spun
is following all this for us from our
Washington bureau David what do we know
at this hour hey Tucker we are just
learning this in the last few minutes
literally just rushed in the studio this
is the memo right here from the Trump
administration I want to read a
statement from press secretary Sarah
Stander's just briefly go over it she
just says today at the request and
recommendation of the Attorney General
president Trump directed the
intelligence community to quickly and
fully cooperate with the Attorney
General's investigation into
surveillance activities during the 2016
election the Attorney General has also
been delegated full and complete
authority to declassify information
pertaining to this investigation in
accordance with long-established
standards for handling classified
information
this action will ensure that all
Americans learn the truth about the
events that occurred and the actions
that were taking during the last
presidential election and restore
confidence in our public institutions
again this is a two-page memo I'm
looking at it right now memorandum for
the secretary of state secretary of
treasury other cabinet officials coming
from President Donald Trump a statement
coming from press secretary Sarah
Sanders declassifying that information
on the intelligence related spying into
that 2016 campaign breaking right now
Tucker but we'll be sure to follow it an
amazing story
I'm sure we'll be hearing very soon
about how we don't have a right to see
it if it's been great to see you tonight
thank you thank you Tucker